la restauration de la collégiale de
mantes-la-jolie a repris après une phase
de travaux d'urgence achevé en 2017 un
grand plan de rénovation va avoir lieu
jusqu'en 2023
un programme de restauration qui a été
établie par des spécialistes
il se déroulera en deux phases la phase
une c'est les terrasses les tribunes et
la mise hors d'eau d'un certain nombre
de choses c'est à dire éviter que
l'édifice ne se dégrade plus en faisant
des travaux et ensuite un travail aussi
sur les cours cible sur les élévations
contre les élévations tribunes et sur
les maçonneries l'édifice étant
propriété de la mairie c'est elle qui
organise les rénovations difficile de
trouver des spécialistes pour les
travaux et encore plus après l incendie
d notre dame de paris et surtout le coût
est important remet sur à peu près sur
les phases une et deux à trois millions
cinq cent mille euros de travaux toutes
taxes comprises donc c'est quand même
d'aider et montant important mais
heureusement on est accompagné on est
accompagné par la région par le
département par l'état via la direction
régionale des affaires culturelles et
aussi par du mécénat privé mais pour la
mairie comme pour le curé ces travaux
sont plus que nécessaires
cette collégiale qui date de plus de 800
ans et la fierté de mantes-la-jolie un
immense bâtiment comme celui-là
multiséculaire depuis 13ème 14ème siècle
il faut absolument qu'ils aient des
rénovations quasi permanente
c'est une des plus grandes églises des
yvelines surtout aussi ancien c'est la
plus grande et on pourrait dire de tout
l'ouest parisien
c'est
l'agr la grande église gothique de
l'ouest parisien mais pour les fidèles
et les touristes pas d'inquiétude les
travaux n'auront pas d'impact sur des
célébrations et sur l'ouverture de la
collégiale